دائما الاجابه عن هذا التسا تبدا بالاسم
مو منطق احد يسالك ممكن يتعرف وتقوله احب
فيلم شاوشنك واي صفه فيك مهما اعتقدت انها
مهمه غير اسمك الاسم هو
الواجهه المعرفه البشريه مرتبطه بالاسماء
ومحدوده
باللغه عندنا اسم لكل
شيء عندنا هوس كافي بالاسماء لدرجه ان
عندنا اسم للا شيء وظريف كمان عندنا اسم
لنفسنا ما ادري مت يكون استخدامه الا لو
مثلا فجاه الا لو فجا فاجون الفضائيين
وسالنا ايش اسمكم وقول لهم احنا نسمي
نفسنا بشر وعلى فكره نسمي فضائيين رغم انه
ما كنا عارفين انكم حتى موجودين ولا لا في
تجربه عن ارتباط المسمى بالاسم تجربه
شهيره
جدا الشكلين في الصوره احدهم سحابي مستدير
والاخر نجمي حاد المطلوب منكم انكم
تتخيلوا اي من الشكلين اسمه بوبا واي
منينهم اسمه
كيكي لا احد يغشش
[ضحك]
احد كم واحد جابها
صح حسب الدراسات 98% من الناس بيربطوا
بوبه بالشكل السحابي المستدير وكيكه بنجم
الحاد كيكي اوكي نفس اقعد مع 2% اللي
يشوفوه
غلط هنا يبدا يتبادر التساؤل متى بدات
معان الاسماء كبشر متى اهتمينا بها
كمسلمين يعتقد انه ربنا من عدله علمها
الانسان الاول ونحنا توارثناها وعلم ادم
الاسماء كلها لكن نحاول نجيب سيناريو على
هرم مازلو الاحتياجات النفسيه والانسانيه
نبدا بقاعده الهرم الانسان كان يحتاج
الاسماء عشان يفرق ما بين الاشياء اللي
ياكلها والاشياء اللي تاكله الاحتياجات
الفسيولوجيه الاحتياجات
السفايف وسط الهرم احتياجات الاجتماعيه
معقده اكثر مثلا كان في اثنين مريم وعبد
الوهاب جيت انا من اللام مكان قررت اسميهم
ماما وبابا اخلق نفسي مكان واخلق لهم
وظيفه من هذا
الاسم قمه الهرم الذات هي موضوعي اليوم
الان ايش المسميات اللي اللي تناسبني ايش
مسميات الصفات
او مين انا اعرفكم بنفسي احمد بوبح دائما
رده الفعل كانت بتكون ايش واكرر بوبح اكثر
من مره وفي النهايه نادوني احمد ويلتفت
معي ع لان مدارس جدا من ايام المدرسه كنت
كنت منزعج من الموضوع طالب باسم خاص بي
زملائي
سمعوني
تويتي لانه كان راسي كبير وجسمه صغير مع
الوقت كانوا بيعطوني مسميات بقر منها
صفاتي اكثر بفهم منها ايش هم يشوفوا عني
حتى لو كانت على سبيل النكته انت تقدر
تفهم منها ايش هم يشوفوك لما يسموك ويردو
مفهي او اي كلمه بتوصف انك انت مختلف عنهم
في ذا الجانب
ما كنت احب المدرسه
اللحق روون المدرسه كانت تحبني وكنت جيد
في في الدرجات وفي التحصيل الاكاديمي لكن
اللي ما كان يعجبني في المدرسه انه في
قوالب سمونا كلنا طلاب ويتوقع ان نتصرف
بنفس الطريقه وتوقعوا انه ربنا ما خلقنا
بوجوه مختلفه عشان نلبس يونيفورم ونفكر
بنفس
الطريقه
ف خلصت الثانويه
حاولت اخرج من كل قالب علمتني اه المدرسه
حتى لو كانت شكلي يعني قصات الشعر اللي
كانت ممنوعه في المدرسه حتى لو كانت سخي ف
جربتها جد
[تصفيق]
فعلا ومع الوقت حاولت اوجه اللي حولي
نادوني بوبح اليوم قليلين جدا يعرفوا ان
اسمي اصلا الاول احمد الاغلب يناديني ببح
حتى في السوشيال نتورك كتبت الفيسبوك بسبح
الموضوع مو جديد ابدا يعني في تاصيل
تاريخي للموضوع العرب زمان كان ينادى
بكنيته ولقبه اختارهم مو اسمه النسبي مثلا
كم واحد يعرف ان ابو بكر الديق ابو بكر
الصديق هو عبد الله بن قحافه قليل
جدا اتخصص
ديزاين المدرسه كانت برض بتعلمنا ايش
اسماء تحد من تصوراتنا عن المستقبل مين ما
يعرف هذه طبيب مهندس طيار اللسته هذه اللي
كلهم يعرفوها ما ما قبلت بها ابدا اخترت
ديزاين لانه بحب التخصص الظريف كمان انه
تخصصنا كانوا بيعلمونا نسمي الاشياء
المنتجات الشركات الان في عملي بنسمي توك
شوز بنسمي قناه على اليوتيوب قريب ان شاء
الله بتطلع فذا عمق اهتمامي بالاسماء نرجع
للنقطه الاولى الاسماء اللي توصفنا نحنا
كاشخاص اللي اللي ممكن تضمني كقالب داخلها
بدات ابحث اول شي في الابراج انه ليبرا او
ميزان الصفات المندرجه تحته اللي تنطبق عل
فعلا لكن مو كلها وما اقدر اقبل ب كقالب
واقول انا ميزان دائما بحث في اختبارات
الشخصيه اكثر مين ما يحب اختبارات الشخصيه
اختبار ضروري تجلبه اسمه امبي تي يقسم نا
16 شخصيه حط تي بي مع
اينشتاين بس ما كان قالب كافي
لسه كانت لسه في صفات ما ما تصالحت معها
داخلي ماان اعرف اصلا ايش ممكن اسميها ال
ما صديقه اقترحت ان عندي اي دي اتش دي نقص
التركيز وفرط الحركه زي ما انتم
[تصفيق]
شايفين من الاعراض كمان لنقص التركيز وفط
الحركه التعبيري اللي كان ممكن البعض
يعتبروا
وقاحه الا لما الكلاسين عن السايكولوجي
وعرفت انه كيف ممكن فاول لقاء مع الناس
انبهم انه انا ايدي اتش دي وانبه التوابع
تبعها خصوصا لو كان لقاء عمل او بيترتب
عليه تعامل دائم فكان فعال جدا انك تختار
مسمى صفتك للناس تعيه بها يعني مثلا هم
ممكن يسموا مزاجيتك كسل لو انت ما قلت لهم
ان انا احب اشتغل بروجان واحب اخذ وقتي
ممكن يسموا اندفاعك تعب وقاحه او اي شيء
من هذه
المسميات هنا نجي لقانون
ممكن
نسميه
لزكت او انه في اتجاه عكسي للموضوع يعني
زي ما يسموك بتتصرف زي ما تتصرف
بيسموك اليومين اللي راحت لما كان وقت
التدريب يقول استاذ احمد استاذ بابح كنت
بتصرف بطريقه جاده ولانه قالوا لي استاذ
فعلا لما احد بتسميه اسم بصرف تبع
له هنا نبدا نراعي كل الصفات اللي اطلقت
علينا مهما كان مصدرها حتى لو انسان نكره
اطلق صفه ظالمه ممكن لها وجه من الصحه
لازم نركز عليها ناخذها بعين الاعتبار كل
الصفات اللي تطلق علينا ال ما نوصل وعي
كافي بنفسنا يتعدى حدود الاسماء ونقول انا
مو ليبرا انا مو اي دي اتش دي انا مو اي
واحده من المسميات هذه انا انا سمي نفسي
انا هنا كمان ضروري نراعي انه لما نطلق
مسميات او احكام على الغير نحاول
نكون ايجابيين او على اقل
موضوعيين ما نحكم مع
الناس واخر شيء انه اهميه رحله معرفه
النفس معرفه النفس يربطها الدين بمعرفه
الرب اللي هو مراعاه لادراك له 99 اسم لو
طلعت على حده منها بتفقد التركيز واهتموا
بسكم
[تصفيق]
شكرا